Nos dicen: "La casa de Kai está a x kilómetros
de la nevería, mientras que la casa de Juan Pablo
está a y kilómetros de la misma tienda. Ellos
salen de sus casas al mismo tiempo y se encuentran
en la nevería en el mismo momento. Kai camina a
una velocidad promedio de 5 kilómetros por hora y
Juan Pablo conduce su bicicleta a una velocidad
promedio de v kilómetros por hora. Escribe una
ecuación que relacione x, y y v." Pausa el video
e intenta encontrar la respuesta. Bien, primero
recordemos cómo es que la distancia, la velocidad
y el tiempo están relacionados. Seguramente estás
familiarizado con que la distancia es igual a la
rapidez por el tiempo, u otra forma de escribirlo
es que la distancia = la velocidad • el tiempo.
Bien, pero si queremos despejar al tiempo,
podemos dividir ambos lados por la velocidad,
de tal manera que obtendremos que: la distancia
/ la velocidad = al tiempo. Ahora, la razón por la
que lo escribimos de esta manera es porque sabemos
que el tiempo de Kai y el tiempo de Juan Pablo son
iguales; tal vez recorran distancias distintas,
quizá a velocidades diferentes, pero les tomó
exactamente la misma cantidad de tiempo. Por lo
tanto, la distancia de Kai entre su velocidad debe
de ser la misma que la distancia de Juan Pablo
entre su velocidad. Así que vamos a escribirlo:
la distancia de Kai -la distancia de Kai-, entre
su velocidad -entre la velocidad de Kai-, debe
de ser igual a la distancia de Juan Pablo -debe
de ser igual a la distancia de Juan Pablo-, entre
su velocidad -entre la velocidad de Juan Pablo-.
Ahora bien, ¿qué conocemos en esta expresión?,
o, dicho de otra manera: ¿tenemos variables para
representar? Bueno, sabemos que la distancia de la
casa de Kai a la nevería es x, así que esto está
representado por x; sabemos que la distancia de
la casa de Juan Pablo a la nevería es y, así que
esto es y. También sabemos que la velocidad de Kai
es 5 kilómetros por hora, por lo tanto, suponiendo
que todo está en kilómetros por hora, esto será
5, y por último también sabemos que la velocidad
de Juan Pablo es de v kilómetros por hora, así
que esto es v. Por lo tanto, podemos reescribir
todo esto como: x / 5 = y / v. Una vez más: esto
lo organizamos de manera que del lado izquierdo
tenemos la cantidad de tiempo que le lleva a Kai
llegar a la nevería; mientras que del lado derecho
tenemos la cantidad de tiempo que le lleva a Juan
Pablo llegar a la nevería, y nos dicen que es la
misma cantidad de tiempo. Así que ya lo tenemos,
tenemos una ecuación que relaciona x, y y v, y nos
dan el 5. Ahora bien, es completamente posible
que en lugar del 5 nos den otro dato, y que la
velocidad de Kai sea una variable; si lo hicieran,
tendríamos un dato distinto y tal vez una variable
distinta, pero la estructura de nuestra ecuación
sería la misma: la distancia de Kai, dividida
por su velocidad, tendría que ser igual a la
distancia de Juan Pablo dividida por su velocidad.